[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
Press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages so time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mirrors associate editor Kevin McGuire
and the Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine
with us from now until just before
midnight welcome to both of you so to
the front pages then let us start with
the Metro which looks at the economic
toll of today's strikes reporting that
since last summer they've cost the
economy around 2 billion pounds now that
really hurts they say
the guardian understands the National
Audit office is looking at whether to
launch an investigation into the
decision to allow taxpayers money to be
used to employ Boris Johnson's private
lawyers for the party gate inquiry
the eye suggests that a return to
Frontline politics by the short-lived
prime minister Liz tras could lead to
further divisions within the
conservative party
the RAF faces a crisis over its drive
for diversity that's on the front page
of the Delhi Telegraph
The Daily Mirror calls for stricter
action on dangerous dogs in the wake of
the death of four-year-old Alice stones
Daily Express reports on the ongoing
search for missing mother of two Nicola
bully and her parents fear that she's
been abducted
the financial times says a multi-billion
dollar share sale to raise funds by
indian-owned conglomerate adani
Enterprise has been called off after its
share price slumped a new law to stop
School strike Mayhem as teachers could
be forced to tell Schools they're
striking ahead of time that's the lead
for the Daily Mail and the sun has a
world exclusive reporting that the
government is planning measures to
better regulate football club takeovers
and give fans more say in running them
well reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages
optimized newspapers while you watch us
let's head straight to Kevin McGuire and
Sarah Vine
um so so let's take a look at the Metro
now it really hurts and uh the point our
political correspondent um was saying
earlier was there comes a point surely
where the cost of the strikes outweighs
the cost of paying people the extra
money in their pay packet so are we
nearly there
uh well I don't know two billion pounds
seems like quite a lot of money to me I
don't know what the maths of it is but
yes I mean it is crippling it's costing
this country an awful lot of money
um I suppose some people would argue
that if the government had just given
them a pay rise then that money wouldn't
have been wasted others would argue that
uh you know the government can't be held
to Ransom by strikes I mean the problem
is is that everybody else is just stuck
in the middle in a sort of nightmare of
you know everything is paralyzed you
can't do anything my son wasn't able to
go to school today and even if he had he
probably wouldn't have been able to get
there because nothing was running so you
know it's it's just an ongoing
um Mexican standoff between the
government and the strike and the unions
and and I just wish they would just get
on and sort it out it's all those
ancillary businesses isn't it Kevin you
know the coffee shop by the station the
Central City you know restaurant that's
not getting anybody in you know Cafe
sandwich shops all of that are
eventually impacted I mean working out
the true cost is going to be is going to
be difficult it's hard enough working
out how many schools were closed today
isn't it um but but but at what point
does the standoff wither away do you
think or does it not the rmt union
talking about you know heading through
the spring with this action no but but
you're right I know these these figures
are always large you know two billion
nice round figure how accurate it is but
certainly in the in the rail industry
the transport Minister Hugh merryman
said they've already gone beyond the
point uh where paying uh higher increase
would have been cheaper than holding out
the cost of the industry because the
real companies uh are compensated by the
government for taxpayers money bizarrely
but if you've got a cafe on a station
you don't you don't get that and the
only way to get out of these strikes is
to negotiate try and find common ground
and push forward and at the moment they
all seem to be going backwards and uh
the industrial action is getting is
getting more intense we've seen
firefighters this week vote that they
will join them at some point the next uh
Union
um strike on in education England Wales
National Education Union isn't for 27
days that surely should be enough time
to get some negotiations going to try
and get them postponed because as you
say there is an impact on the economy
it's it's who you play blame whose side
do you take and at the moment the
government is losing the propaganda war
and getting more blame than the trade
unions yes we heard Oliver Dowden again
on Sky News this evening saying you
can't bake inflation into the system but
I suppose the point is once you give a
pay rise Sarah you know that pay rise is
Hell forever so the cost to the taxpayer
is baked in you know from from then on
why well Kevin's frowning at me the pay
increase last does it not you know your
weight is already higher
yeah but if you if you have inflation
it's ten and a half percent that is
ongoing you've lost a tenth of your
spending power already so that that is
baked in bacon in in inflation a lot of
these increases wouldn't be directly
inflationally because we don't charge
for Education we don't charge for health
so I understand if there's a private
company and it gives a pay rise and then
it puts up prices to recoup that that
can be inflationary but it isn't the
case in education it certainly isn't the
case in health
in the fire service yeah I'm saying the
government says they're baking in
inflation I'm saying they're baking in
the cost to the taxpayers like two
separate things there right yeah but but
if inflation came or is essentially will
say Putin and Ukraine big shock to the
system British economy is very weak uh
as we saw the IMF report we're doing
worse another comparable economies am I
going to do better in in the future give
a lot to take some response for that but
it's these wage demands aren't driven by
you know they aren't driving inflation
inflation is driving the waste demands
Dowden has just got it completely
rounded his neck and he's looking at it
the wrong way okay Sarah that I mean
that question was due but should we move
on to the front of the year
which is this this idea that uh the
unions did not need to say specifically
which teachers Were Striking
um suggestion was they'd actually ask
teachers not to tell their heads if they
were on strike teachers are having to
work it out by asking who was not
striking
um an idea of a new law to stop uh
parents being left in limbo so tell us
about that
yeah I mean the thing is is that if your
child's school is on strike and if your
child's not going to be able to go into
school you do need to know because you
will have to make arrangements so to be
honest it's not just teachers sorry it's
not just head teachers so this would
help it's also parents and you know I've
got lots of colleagues who've had to
stay at home today to look after their
children because obviously they can't go
to work if their children are at home so
it's not you know it's just a
I understand that for the unions it has
more effects because it's more K it
creates more chaos but it's not fair on
head teachers who are trying to run a
school and it's also not fair on on on
parents and on children I mean my my son
is doing his a-levels you know every day
that he's not at school is an issue
absolutely I'm sorry I know teachers
yeah the doc the dog wants to get out
doesn't it um and they would they were
trying to prioritize um children in exam
years weren't they but obviously it's
not it's not always possible
you could always get up and open a door
while I talk to Kevin but there we are
um
someone outside there isn't anyone
outside
oh
yeah there's a big dog no it's a tiny
little Lhasa Apso it's a Tibetan Temple
guardian and it thinks I'm its Temple
and that you know the hordes are coming
to get me yeah we're invading the temple
Kevin it's a problem tonight anyway
I've been barking yeah
uh let's go to the guardian shall we um
now then this is uh Boris Johnson
defending himself against partygate
allegations where does he get the money
for the defense
um take it away
if it's me uh yeah the national order
office officials are just looking at the
cost of legal advice for Boris Johnson I
think I think it's a fair principle if a
if a government minister in the line of
his or her duty is subsequently going to
face legal action because of their the
position they held then they should get
legal advice now there's two questions
here one is was Johnson really
personally culpable should it be
publicly supported I think he probably
should but secondly then it's the cost
how is that bill so high that is
enormous absolutely enormous I mean he's
going to face a Commons uh privileges
Committee hearing uh there'll be a
public inquiry down down the line but
that is a big big Bill Sarah just is it
a good is it good spending of taxpayers
money yeah I mean lawyers are very
expensive I mean the thing is that I
think Kevin's right he did lose his job
because of these allegations and you
know in any other situation that that is
what would happen I think I think it's
right that he should have this help but
it doesn't he's too it's 222 000 pounds
I mean I suppose the real question here
is why do lawyers charge so much
uh to the eye now fascinating
conversation this week after the IMF
report uh put the UK uh down the league
tables um on the growth for the next
year about why our growth is bad and
what needs to be done about it which has
brought a lot of the trust Heights back
anyway here's the eye front page now
Kevin Liz truss come back ignites fears
of a new Tory Civil War a comeback
already
I know the woman with no shame after she
crashed the economy which uh I think the
conservative estimate was a 30 billion
cost as a rescue package for Pension
funds needed to be interest rates went
up the pound fell absolutely incredible
but the Kia Stamo must think he's having
a birthday every day you've got Boris
Johnson stalking Rishi sudak who
probably needs to take out a restraining
order and now you've got Liz Tross
rearing her head just to remind all the
voters about the other chaos she is she
Unleashed it's it's weird politics yes
it's it's always thank they keep coming
back now the end of the John Major era
when the clitor of party was falling
apart very factional and didn't want to
be led
yeah
it's the Eternal Tory tragedy but I do
think let's trust him to speed
everything up she was premised in 40
days and now she's only been gone for
about three weeks and she's already
making a comeback so you know it's it's
just Bonkers I I I don't understand why
anyone credible in the Tory party is is
is an even remotely entertaining this
concept it's just not con it's just
unhelpful to the Tory party and to the
country I mean I want to see more of
Kamikaze I know I want to see a launcher
leadership bid
but we've got enough problems with Matt
Hancock Liz truss enough yes Dominic Rob
yeah how far the um comeback comes um
the former prime minister is preparing
for her Westminster return after her
breather and will demand policies that
drive growth sparking Panic among Tory
back benches the next cabinet minister
telling the eye that the conservative
party risks a new era of factionalism so
you've got Johnson in Eve in Washington
you've got Liz truss back you've
certainly got those who are pro-growth
um you know to give them the loose's
title
um speaking out after the IMF reports
era
um you know do they not realize the
precarious position they are in the
polls as we head you know fairly rapidly
now towards a general election
I'm really I I don't know they clearly
don't and they clearly don't understand
that what the country really wants now
is stability continuity you know
sensible person in charge who's not
going to do any grandstanding or come up
with any crazy ideas that are going to
crash the economy everybody wants growth
but you know there's a process that has
to happen you have to put the put the
put the ingredients in the mix in order
to be able to achieve that growth you
can't just kind of Waltz in and say oh
yes no let's have some growth next
Thursday which is is Bonkers they need
to they need to be grown up about this
and and most people in the story party
ah the problem is there's a lot of vocal
there's a vocal minority who are just
you know to quote George Osborne
civilized loons who just will not stop
someone said it anyway yeah we'll we'll
look it up next time don't worry about
it uh in the meantime um the strategy
for secure starma seems now to attack
the Prime Minister Rishi sunak and we're
told they will become increasingly
personal because he is outpolling his
party you know you could say Labor's
damage is the party or they've damaged
themselves who knows about the Tories uh
but it is is we should soon now in the
sights for labor do you think Kevin
oh yes the conservative party appears to
have a president sunac approach pushing
him forward
um stalmer outposts soon act but you can
see that he's a problem it was you
watched prime minister as today and it's
all you know the Tories it's all sleaze
and Scandal and sunak is hopelessly weak
with terrible judgment and he seems to
know nothing until after everybody else
which it was on Gavin Williamson then it
became the deems awari and now the you
know the Caravans moved on to Dominic
road but yeah I think it's a little bit
unfair I don't think he's completely in
the dark I mean I think on rob the key
thing is is that there there were no
formal complaints given to Rishi so you
know you can't just you know Sarah
didn't you you knew I I I maybe I bet
Dominic once and he was very nice to me
but I guess he probably would be nice to
me so you know I'm probably not a
reliable witness but I but you know you
can't fire somebody on the basis of
rumors you have to there has to be due
process and I think he's doing the right
thing let's just wait and see what what
the what the inquiry or whatever it is
they're going to do tells us and if he
if he is a bully then obviously he
should go and if he's not then then not
and what do you feel you feel he's going
to have to go don't you
I I couldn't possibly comment I'm just
going to do something about my dog if
you would excuse me
on that note we'll take a break Sarah's
not going to be drawn as you can see
anyway lots more still to come in the
next part of our program we will look at
why the RAF has been forced to defend
its recruiting practices when we come
back
foreign
[Music]
with me once again Kevin McGuire and
Sarah Vine um Sarah let's go to the
Daily Telegraph shall we um the RAF
facing a crisis over its drive for
diversity
um white men were discriminated against
in 160 cases the paper says with this
push for women and ethnic minorities
tell us more
yes well I mean it's not often you read
a headline that says white men
discriminated against but I mean in this
case I think what's happened here is
that there's a sort of there's a bit of
wokeness going on which is that they've
decided that they need to have more
women and ethnicity minorities but the
problem is is that you need if you're
going to be flying fighter jets you just
need the best person to fly the fighter
jet so I can sort of see why you would
say maybe in your back office or in your
Administration stuff you would have some
sort of diversity recruitment drive but
at the end of the day when it's talk
when you're talking about soldiers or
Fighters you've just got to have the
best person for the job and you have to
be I think you can't judge by sex or by
or by or by race you've just got to take
who does it best
um and in this case uh they didn't uh
they got carried away and I think
um uh one of the someone resigned in
fact a woman resigned over this because
she said it was impossible for her to do
her job uh because she was so hamstrung
by this sort of directive yeah I mean it
was our security and defense uh editor
Deborah Haynes who first brought the
world here this story um last year but
certainly to buy a Sellwood um chair of
the commons defense Select Committee in
questioning the head of the RAF did
point out that everyone had passed their
exams it's just that just that the best
ones he suggested were not being
promoted Kevin
yeah but the the air Chief Marshall uh
denied there'd be any impact on on
standards and it all seemed to be lots
of conjecture here
um the you want fight for pilot you want
the the best Pilots of course but you
want to widen the talent pool and if
people of color
um black britons britons of Asian origin
of the heritage of being ignored or
women when you're getting a con and you
get into a cockpit uh then then you want
you want to make sure you've got the
best why why would the best always be
you know some Posh private Schoolboy
very odd way to say it's 160 people
discriminated against white men rather
than rather than saying look they've
actually widened it to get they get the
most talented
yes but if the people who are the most
talented don't happen to comply with the
diversity laws then that doesn't make
sense you've just got to have the best
person I think the problem no I agree
you you want the best
people if they would have been if
they've been ignoring all these uh you
know these people from various uh other
other backgrounds whether they're male
or female whether they're of color or
white women and they've just been going
to the same people Time After Time After
Time or is it the case that that people
from uh different backgrounds and women
don't really feel that the armed forces
are a career path for them which is
probably what the situation is so they
don't tend to be drawn to those jobs and
that is a that is a different thing and
that's something that you can only
really change over time so that's about
making the armor forces more receptive
to people who might not necessarily feel
they were naturally at home there and
that is a that is an important thing
what you can't do is is sort of suddenly
make the armed forces less efficient
because you want to have a quota in a
period of a year there's no evidence
Sarah that it's been made less efficient
it's kind of Defending a privilege and
saying look we've got this group we've
always had this group we're going to
keep this group and we're going to lock
all these other people out
well no particularly the reason they
they say that these people have been
discriminated against this presumably
resume because they're that maybe they
we don't know the details but maybe
they've been doing it for longer or
they've got more expertise or they've
got more flight hours or whatever I
don't know how it works but there will
be reasons why these people it weren't
just because they're white it's because
they've got the experience
I mean just because just because
somebody
you know it doesn't mean that if you are
a white male and you should know this
Kevin that you are you know you're a
very experienced journalist
and you know we all enjoy your your
views and your and your experience
just because of your color doesn't mean
say that you're you should give away to
somebody who's less experienced because
they're a woman for example yeah but you
but you know Sarah flute street
newsrooms now have far more women than
they used to and I think they're better
for us that's a process that has taken
place over quite a long period of time
and it's it's it's quite organic and it
has happened because more and more women
have been have felt able to come into
the profession and have felt able to do
well in the profession that is something
that obviously needs to be encouraged
but you can't just it's not a switch
that you can flick is all I'm saying
we've run out of time we didn't do
Delilah being banned that great Tom
Jones song uh anyway we'll see you later
thank you both very very much indeed